[Musique]
donc
je pense que les suédois
prennent de grandes responsabilités donc si vous êtes
malade nous restons à la maison
et si nous ne le sommes pas nous pouvons être à l'extérieur ce
serait bien pour moi de porter un masque
bien sûr mais si le  la recommandation
n'est pas là où
ce n'est pas de ne pas le porter mais s'ils disent que
ça
va sans nous sans oui nous
attendons s'ils décident
cela
parce que s'ils ne le décident pas je
ne le porterai pas parce que
personne d'autre ne le fera  Je sais que l'
opinion officielle est que ce n'est pas
si nécessaire parce que si vous ne manipulez pas
le masque
d'accord, c'est pire que de l'avoir sur
vous, vous savez que vous pouvez
aussi avoir un virus sur vos doigts
[Musique]
six ouais je veux dire
si vous regardez quoi  l'
organisation internationale a déclaré qu'elle avait dit qu'un masque facial
pouvait être quelque chose que vous pouvez
ajouter si vous ne pouvez pas empêcher les gens de
se presser et ainsi de suite jusqu'à présent, la situation
n'a pas été comme ça en suède
et en ce moment, nous avons une situation avec une
baisse rapide du nombre de cas
sans masques faciaux, puis introduire des
masques faciaux dans cette situation n'aurait
bien sûr pas beaucoup de sens
Roberta a déclaré que si nous avions une
augmentation rapide du nombre de cas si de nouvelles
connaissances se mettent en place,
bien sûr, nous continuons à évaluer quand le
masque facial fait réellement  la différence
pour la propagation des saisons
[Musique]
vous